welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy who's just like loki because i'm
your brother from another mother
what is happening youtube it's been what
feels like an elf sage and i'm so hyped
because episode 1 of the disney plus
show
is now out worldwide in this video we're
going to be breaking down the story
easter eggs things you missed and also
giving our theories on where the show
could be going in the future
now the series feels like it's going to
be heavily based on several graphic
novels
starring the god of mischief these
include vote loki
and loki agent of asgard the latter
seems like it's inspiring the basic
premise of the show
and in that we pick up at a point where
loki's reputation has spiraled out of
control
because of this he's unable to escape
from being called the bad son
the bad brother the worst youtuber that
keeps banging on about mephisto
and he's one of the most hated people in
the marvel universe
however when he dies everything changes
and he's reincarnated into a younger
body
loki becomes an agent of asgard and the
old mother tells him that for every good
deed he performs that a bad one from his
past
will be struck up the list the old
mother appears as three heads at one
point
and this may have been adapted into the
timekeeper monuments that we see
dotted throughout the century though
they are also their own characters
now in the book he attempts to get the
sword of sigurd which
is the manifestation of truth and along
the way he runs into
mephisto i'm not i'm not even gonna go
down that path again
now he also faces off against another
version of himself
which this show is clearly setting up
both that book
and vote loki feature alternate versions
of the character
which of course plays into the idea that
there are several variants of loki
running around
now one thing that you have to
understand about the incarnation that we
see here
is that he's only appeared in two mcu
movies at this point
in this entry we also come face to face
with the tva
or rather the time variance authority so
far in the mcu we've dealt with a lot of
agencies such as shield and sword
but whereas they dealt more with the big
three the tva
are sort of time cops however they're
also bureaucrats
obsessed with rules and regulations and
we very much get this idea throughout
the episode at several points
first name dropped in issue 372 of thor
the group later went on to have a much
bigger part in
issue 353 of the fantastic four here
they arrested marvel's first family for
crimes against time travel
and we also learned a lot more about
them it was revealed in that issue that
the tva
operated in an old time zone and we met
one of their high officials
mobius and mobius played by owen wilson
in the show
the character is so secretive that i
couldn't even find an entry for him
in the marvel encyclopedia however the
internet
furthermore shows why it's superior to
reading books and i've copied his wiki
to make it seem like i know what i'm
talking about
he was put in charge of the fantastic
four but after they escaped he was
demoted
he's also worked with the kang dynasty
and was one of the head judges during
she-hulk's trial
something that may or may not come up in
her spin-off show
now the name mobius first appeared in
the mcu during endgame
when tony used a mobius strip to solve
time travel
and that movie massively plays into the
show the avengers mess with time in that
movie
and though steve went back and closed
off most of the branch timelines before
finally getting rid of that b
chord loki is a definite offshoot the
timekeepers too come from the comics
and they were created by he who should
not be next sorry
he who remains this was the last time
keeper who placed them at the end of the
universal cycle
so that there would be beings who would
avoid repeating the mistakes of the past
now the episode itself picks up during
the events of endgame
namely the moment that loki managed to
escape before the rest of us had to deal
with 2020
now we get a scrolling through the years
to 2012
and this title chord is used throughout
the episode to denote when we're in a
certain time period
there's an added shot here that wasn't
an endgame in which we get a close-up of
loki
to bring more focus to him loki grabs
the tesseract
and we cut to the marvel studios logo
which turns green
a color that is of course synonymous
with loki now from here
we jump to the gobi desert in mongolia
to watch as loki crashes into sand dunes
after teleporting there
this shot of him flying through the air
and then sitting up in the sand with
scraps around him
is very similar to when tony first
escaped the cave all the way back in the
first iron man film
i feel like this is done on purpose here
as the two shots carry the idea that
they were characters heading down the
wrong path
but both were given a second chance and
a shot at redemption
again it's like poetry they so sorry
wrong franchise
now just before this shot we see a drop
of water hanging off a rock
and the way that a bug appears inside of
it and then crawls out
i feel has some symbolic meaning this
very much seems like a metaphor for the
show
and how at this point we are very much
bursting out of the bubble
and into exploring the multiverse in the
mcu natives to the area arrive
and loki quickly rushes to a rock to
tower over the top of them
the character is still obsessed with
ruling and as we learn in avengers
during his conversation with thor
he very much sees himself as being above
everyone else
however loki is knocked down a pekka two
by the arrival of the minutemen
who come through a doorway to take not
only the tesseract but also the god of
mischief
they're led by hunter b-15 who if you're
a fan of this channel
you might recognize from our lovecraft
country breakdowns
or maybe we're just a fan of the show
guys let's be honest we're not that big
yet now she calls him a variant i think
we've all heard
enough about them lately b15 lights up a
disintegration stick that we see her use
throughout the entry
and we also saw something similar being
used by the grandmaster and thor
ragnarok
however instead of killing him she
instead stuns him into moving a
sixteenth of the speed of normal time
in order to strap a collar on him that
basically allows them to rick and morty
him back to a certain point
in order to destroy all evidence that he
was ever there
the minutemen set up a temporal charge
and the mysterious loki figure at the
end of the entry grabs one of these
to no doubt caused some mischief in the
animation we later see
it shows that these completely wipe out
entire timelines
so sorry guys but they've just made you
terence howard
now loki is taken through a doorway and
when this closes we can see some tiles
with a regular circle patterns on them
behind him
this pattern too appears in the carpet
of the court and it might be a subtle
nod to the timelines and branch
realities being out of whack
and it might also be a reach now when
loki is brought in
if you look to the right you can see a
scroll and after showing up in captain
marvel
far from home and one division it's
clear that these are starting to
populate the mcu more and more
we are of course ramping up to secret
invasion so
them slowly starting to slot them into
the shows and movies
is teasing towards that the son of a
board member at goldman sachs is brought
in
and he's later wiped out now the
tesseract is handed over to kc
and when the show was first being
promoted i did think that the fact
logie had taken an infinity stone would
have been the reason why the tva were
after him
in endgame we learned from the ancient
one that removing one from the time
stream caused severe issues
and she gave a demonstration of the
timeline with branched realities
that did somewhat look like the one we
see in this episode
however the infinity stones are actually
meaningless to the tva
and they're even used as paperweights
showing how much more powerful the
agency are than
anything thanos could muster when you
think about it they pretty much have all
the power that the stones do anyway
and they're able to alter time reality
bring people back to life
travel across space and so on loki is
put through the ringer
putting clothes made to sign waivers and
also put through the metal detector of
death
he falls through floors the entire time
which could be another thor ragnarok
when strange had him falling for 30
minutes at one point he comes across a
printout of everything he's ever said
and this seemed pretty light for a dude
that's lived for thousands of years
probably talked more in this video than
he has his entire life but
there's also a cat that appears on a mug
and i really hope that this is revealed
to be a flirkin or or something else
now when we see the robot terminator you
can also catch some silver scorch marks
on the side
and i hope we learned that a version of
ultron or something was passed through
here
interestingly we can see that loki's
aura is red
and typically this is thought to
represent an energetic and fiery
personality
which he definitely has he's sent into a
queue and
here we're introduced to miss minute
before we get the animated exposition
done by her
you can also catch a poster saying
behave or you'll get your clock cleaned
this has a picture of her american
history exiting someone and as we see
she doesn't mess around from here we're
told about the multiverse war that took
place between the countless timelines
as they all battled for supremacy these
wars have appeared throughout the comics
and things like the infinity conflict
the eternity war and so on however it's
most likely a reference to secret wars
which several leakers and scoopers have
said is coming down the line
now what i think it's doing is hinting
that the multiverse war is coming again
and that the events of the show will end
with loki somewhat starting one
the show could potentially kick-start a
war across multiple dimensions and
realities
and i think this animation is put in at
the start to tease what's coming down
the line when the tva are no doubt
defeated
now the animation has several different
styles to it pulling from the 70s marvel
cartoons
and also things like the flintstones
during one of the potential offshoot
explanations
we also see what i believe might be the
cree war
in the background you can make out what
i think might be a spiral from titan
and they may have even been waging war
on thanos home
anyway i love this video and it shows
that the time keepers are pretty much
worshipped as gods
loki refers to them as lizards at one
point which is likely a note to the
conspiracy
theory of lizard leaders that state
several members of the royal family and
freemasons
are shape-shifting lizards that wish to
form and control humanity
dinosaurs also came before humans did so
it makes sense that the first kind of
life forms
would be reptilian now the tva's biggest
worry is that a nexus event is created
and this terminology first popped up in
age of ultron
at the point where all information on
the internet flowed through
however the term also appeared at
several points in one division
and wonder herself is actually a nexus
being
which means that she's the same person
across every dimension
loki isn't hence why we're seeing
several different variants of the
character
later on we do see a poster saying nexus
events must be phoned in
so we know that locking them down is of
great importance
there's zero tolerance here and after
the sun of a goldman sachs banker is
wiped out
we cut to the title chord which has a
devil
sign it i'm i'm not going that route i'm
not
now if you're enjoying the video and all
the devil in the details then i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up
if you're not subscribed then make sure
you do as we're going to be doing
breakdowns on the show each and every
week and
you will miss one yeah if if you don't i
promise you that now jumped off you
don't you don't want to miss it now jump
to france
1549 and we see that a loki variant has
been running wild
in this space of a week they've carried
out six attacks and we see that a local
layer has been given a stick of
blueberry kablooey
kablooie means splat and it kind of
hints to what the evil loki variant is
doing
this product doesn't actually exist but
there is
another make of kablooey which has a
slightly different spelling
i think that the show is going to be
exploring things like the mandela effect
and
items like this would be the perfect way
to do that the child says that the devil
did it
and points to an image of the devil and
i mean i mean come on guys the
the they've literally pointed out the
devil and said they did it
mephisto confirmed now
it's more just a reference to how loki
is a mischievous god
much like lucifer who is of course known
for playing big tricks and
i promise i'm not going down that route
again now loki is taken to time court
and we hear him being called loki love
his son thor's surname is odin son
but as we learned loki is a frost giant
so he doesn't have the same name
he's judged by gugu mabatharo's
character who
is ravana and slayer kang and the
conqueror loved her
and it is possible that he will be
popping up in the show at some point
as we do know he's being played by
jonathan mages
who you may also know from lovecraft
country if you watch this channel
which why don't you now the central head
on the timekeepers
it does sort of look a lot like kang and
though i don't think that it's him
potentially he could be taking
inspiration from this deity
however another theory i've been
thinking about quite a lot is that the
timekeepers might not actually exist
and then it could actually be kang who's
behind it all kang
is a big villain that manipulates time
and as no one
ever actually sees the timekeepers i
think him being behind it all would be a
nice little twist
now we can see that the logo of the tva
is a face with
what looks like an hourglass in the
middle of it this is also a bit like the
infinity symbol
potentially tying in with time and the
idea that they exist in the infinite
beyond it
now shouts to my editor christian for
noticing that in the tapestries
we can also make out what looks to be
stan lee since his death marvel have
said they're using more sophisticated
ways to put him into their projects
and this has included a magazine cover
in the venom 2 trailer
and a license plate in one division with
his birthday on it
i couldn't find him in falcon in the
winter soldier so let me know below if
you spotted him
but i do think that this is definitely
how they're paying tribute to him here
loki believes that he would have become
a god king and this is a nod to the
comics in which he was called that
he also says that he could smell the
cologne of two tony starks
which is a nod to when ant-man remarked
on his axe body spray
we learned that the avengers were always
meant to reverse the snap
and this is why the tva didn't intervene
in the events of
endgame loki pleads guilty and tries to
warp his knives in
which we've seen the character do in
several movies however they don't work
hinting to us how powerful that the tva
are
mobius stands up and says that he needs
him for his insight
for which we discover involves hunting
an alternate version of him
you also see for the first time the tva
headquarters and the city itself
looks like it's designed to resemble the
inner workings of a clock
in the center of it we can see the
timekeepers holding up a display of the
time stream
so i think when things eventually go
haywire that this shutting down will
send the entire location into a panic
probably be a bunch of idiots like loki
though that don't think it's real
and will not get into that loki says
that this place is a nightmare
and as you guessed it nightmare
confirmed
now next we see the buttons on an
elevator panel and they all have
alphanumeric codes on them
except for the middle column which
contains an x and an o with a line
through it
this could be hinting towards the x-men
existing off in their own dimension
and let's hope marvel don't pull another
boner when introducing them to the mcu
now mobius introduces himself and loki
says that he doesn't like to talk
mobius retorts this by saying that he
likes to lie and that because of this he
does like to talk
loki being a liar is something that's
well known throughout the universe
and agent loki played on this in several
ways by having book titles like trust me
but loki also dealt with him running a
campaign based completely
on lies so he'll probably end up
becoming the leader of a country
now mobius somewhat interrogates loki
and he says that he wants to rule mid
god
but it becomes clear that he also wants
to oversee the nine realms
he thinks that free will just leads to
regret and bad choices
and in avengers he of course mind
controlled several people
in order to strip them of any agency
mobius plays different events from
loki's life
including the moment in which the
avengers captured him to this loki it
would have happened mere hours before
so this is why he turns away upon seeing
it mobius also drinks just a energy
drink
which no longer exists this was created
by pepsi
but it was discontinued now i do think
that several items we see at the tva hq
will be things that either are no longer
produced or that come from the future
and this is a nice little prop to show
how they can drop in and out of time
mobius played several things from his
past including a big reveal that he was
actually db cooper
in case you don't know the case of db
cooper it's one of the biggest
unsolved mysteries in american history
and the real life figure ended up
hauling a boeing 727 hostage
db collected two hundred thousand
dollars in ransom
and dived out the back of the plane to
never be seen again
all that was found were some crumpled
bills and when loki is teleported out
there by heimdall
we can actually see some of them remain
behind which is a further nod to the
mystery
now it turns out that he lost a bet with
thor so he had to do this
and hopefully we get the reveal that
loki was involved in some of the world's
biggest mysteries
like what happened to the crew of the
mary celeste and who hacked the psn
store
now mobius plays not just his past but
also his future in the mcu
including how his actions led to the
death of his mother
this really breaks loki and i think it's
this moment of self realization
that makes him see he has to choose a
different path the acting is
stellar in these scenes and it really
shows a sight of the god of mischief
that we don't get to see
time is getting short as the tva have
lost another unit
and we see that loki has stolen mobius's
time twister to return back to the lobby
he follows a clerk called casey in order
to get the tesseract
and in his office we see several old ibm
typewriters
casey is unaware of what a fish is
showing how sheltered some of the
workers are
it's here that we find out they have
several infinity stones
which also gives a nod to the power of
the agency now we did learn an endgame
that removing one from the timeline has
disastrous effects
and it is possible that after thanos
destroyed them at the start of the movie
that the tva puts spare ones in their
place
thus the universe could stabilize and it
would also mean that they can pop up
again
once more down the line the tesseract
itself is of course an
infinity stone and the fact that it
still exists does hint to them
potentially returning
b15 misses with her disintegration stick
and we see the effect of it is very
similar to the temporal grenade at the
start of the show
it shows that when someone is struck
with one it very much erases them
completely from existence
loki uses the time twister to return and
he begins to watch his entire life
just seeing the reaction to his father
calling him son completely breaks him
and him learning of his death is
absolutely incredible
he handles it in a much different way to
what thanos did
and it shows the humanity that's
starting to develop within him
hiddleston really brings his acting
chops here and it's a great scene in
which he realizes he can be a hero
and that his brother does love him loki
is massively changed by his death at the
hands of thanos
and this version was of course just
recently working for him
so no doubt he comes to the realization
of what would be in store for him
should he continue to try and rule loki
frees himself
and easily bests b15 using the time
twister to his advantage
this of course shows how he's slowly
getting to grips with being a member of
the tva
now the word time twister actually pulls
from marvel comics 2
and originally these were villains that
thor faced off against
they were actually the first attempt by
he who remains to create the timekeepers
but they were extremely flawed and tried
to destroy the universe
loki explains to mobius that everything
he does is a desperate play for control
and though he sees himself as a villain
that it is possible to change
after coming to the conclusion that if
he returns he's doomed
and that the tva is all-powerful he
enlists in their ranks
and we jump to selena oklahoma 1858
to see a loki varian attacking the
minutemen the character steals a
temporal charge
and will likely be using this to
eradicate each and every one that they
can
now there are of course a lot of
theories floating around about who this
character is
and i love how they keep their face
hidden in order to keep us guessing
in ancient asgard we do meet an older
version of loki
who is still a villainous version
controlling it all and potentially they
could be popping up in the season
there are multiple versions of loki in
the marvel universe and this includes
kid loki
which is an even younger version of the
character well loki who we have of
course seen in the trailers
lady loki and king loki who has popped
up in the teasers too
now i will say that i have seen episode
2 already
as that got sent out for review along
with the first one
i think it would be disingenuous for me
to be like well this is who i think it
is and for them to pop up down the line
as we get more clues
and i'm actually curious to see whether
other youtubers acknowledge this
or just pretend that they don't know who
it is in order to get a fanty rewrite
i'm not going to spoil too much but if
you've seen the trailers
you kind of know what we're in store for
and yes
it is mephisto now i think that we will
very much be dealing with loki
investigating alternate versions of
himself potentially every episode
and this will somewhat shape the variant
we follow into becoming the main one who
outlives the rest
it's even possible that the one in
infinity war could somewhat be a version
of a loki
and that he faked his own death in order
to control the events of the show
anyway lots to talk about and let me
know your theories below
now as for my thoughts on the episode i
feel like this first entry is probably
the second in my ranking for the pilots
so far out of all the mcu shows
falcon and the winter soldier had a
brilliant first episode
and one division was a bit meh to the
point that they had to release it with
two episodes so
i feel like this slots into the middle
of that now whilst it sounds like i
could be slugging off
actually really enjoyed it and loki is
the first character to carry an entire
show on his back
whereas he others like falcon winter
soldier wonder and vision
they were all sort of side characters
coming into their own loki is one of the
most beloved people in the fan community
because of this i was instantly on board
from the start i really think that this
episode managed to show the best
elements of his personality
and how good of an anti-hero that he is
he's a complete dick
but he's also so lovable like another
massive
idiot around here that i can't help but
smile when he's basically just doing
things for himself
i really enjoyed this episode and disney
plus has got another solid show on their
hands by the looks of it
whereas both one division and falcon in
the winter soldier
sort of had to keep the status quo so
that people could jump from
end game into the next set of movies
without getting lost loki can really do
anything there's no rules or setup that
he has to abide by in order for things
to still make sense
and because of this they have a lot of
potential to explore interesting avenues
with the multiverse and branch timelines
loki can really do whatever he wants
without affecting the main one
and it means there's a lot of surprises
that the show could have in store
again i really enjoyed it and i can't
wait to see what comes next
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you comment below
and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
store on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the mcu phase 3 box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of sweet
tooth which will be linked on screen
right now
we've gone over the first season of the
netflix show it's definitely worth
checking
out if you want to know more without the
way thank you for sticking to the video
i'll be ball i'll see you next time take
care
peace